even one hour a day is a lot for a  conversation in another language  but how long do you think it takes to  get fluent if you're conversing with  somebody or attempting to  for an hour a day if you only have one  hour you nee  don't need to have it just one hour of  conversing  because that doesn't give you time to  absorb the information  generally i like to have my conversation  and then after it  that will direct with the study i'm  doing and i might see  you know what i don't know how to say  basic verbs like to eat to sleep  i'm going to go research that i'm going  to create a nanky deck or find one  online and i'm going to study that  it's very difficult to say how long it  will take to get fluent because  it depends on so many factors of that  person's learning experience